[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen mannschaft
fällt und meine lieben freunde hier seht
schon ich befinde mich noch immer auf
meinem tunnel hier unten wartet direkt
zum unterwasser zombie mittel in der
hand wieder den unterwasser angeln ist
aber auch egal meine lieben freunde ihr
seht es bereits im titel und ihr seht es
auch bereits anhand des tempels ich weiß
noch nicht wie ich das darstellen werde
allerdings werde ich in der heutigen
episode keinen einzigen schnitt setzen
ich werde schon so ein bisschen so die
musik mal anfangen lassen mal entlassen
ich finde das ist einfach wichtig dass
das ganze zumindest ein bisschen
musikalische untermalung hat allerdings
werde ich sonst nicht schneiden und das
habe ich in der letzten folge lesen kann
ich ja nicht mal den kommentar
einblenden
ich habe auf jeden fall ein kommentar
gesehen wo sich das team einmal
gewünscht hat weil ich oft sage hey hey
herzlich willkommen mit balu ihr gerade
entgegen gefahren ist oh mein gott
normalerweise würde ich jetzt auch mit
irgendwelchen soundeffekten arbeiten und
jetzt irgendwie balu sondern irgend
einen text oder sowie der mir
entgegenkommt oder so war das mache ich
heute auch nicht ich habe den kommentar
gelesen den ich wie gesagt jetzt nicht
einwenden kann weil es sonst im schnitt
wäre dass ich jetzt einfach mal
ungeschnitten hochladen soll
und ich hab mich dann mal so ein
bisschen gegen gesträubt die sind jetzt
in folge 65 und die ersten 64 folgen
waren alle geschnitten war wie ich finde
die ad hoc ich finde dieser leuchtturm
das sieht alles so geil auf mit diesem
portal schwert und dann siehst du hier
hin so durch die trauer insel am bisher
genannt ich habe auf jeden fall die
ersten 64 folgen alles geschnitten aber
jetzt habe ich bei blue gerade
geschlagen event jetzt auch noch
gestorben weil ich hätte mir das nicht
verzeihen können weil du musst auf jeden
fall wieder mit zurück nach hause kommen
hinten mit mehr die kirche und zwar
schon sehr sehr sehr sehr wild kommt
balu dann hinter mir her
teleportiert er sich ich hab mir dass
meine ja okay er ist auf jeden fall
hinter mir das heißt wir werden ihn
jetzt gleich mal wieder zurück in seine
kleine runde setzen
ich habe auf jeden fall ein kommentar
gelesen dass sich ja oft heimlich zu
sein denn ich mache oft irgendwelche
katz von wegen hey wir sehen uns gleich
wieder ich sag dir schnell die items
oder ich fahre schnell da hinten rüber
oder so weiter und so fort
ihm würde ich eigentlich auch im sound
auf den kopf setzen so dass ich mich mit
ihm unterhalten weil du bleibst hier
will ich hier die links schieben kann
ich dir nicht so dass hier drauf so zac
einmal kurz rechts geht und jetzt kann
ich noch kurze wieder reinschieben so
dass er dann hier vorne erst mal drin
sitzen dann weil ich will nicht noch ein
tier verlieren was ich schon leider sehr
häufig getan habe in diesem projekt wenn
man sich allein mal den friedhof anguckt
ist drin aber erst dann wenn man sich
aber einmal den friedhof angucken und
vor allem auch hinten bei der trauer in
sind hat unseren großen friedhof also
nicht nur unser kleines grab hier vorne
allerdings werde ich mal jetzt erst mal
ganz kurz ein stück verrottetes fleisch
geben weil ich nicht weiß wie sehr ich
ihm geschadet habe durch meinen schlag
wohin also einmal hier das gegessen was
er noch eins das ist gar nicht so genau
ich geb dir einfach mal ein bisschen
mehr dass er sich sein leben auf jeden
fall wieder auffüllt jetzt macht er nur
noch sind zum platzt auseinander also
das sollte auf jeden fall passen also
das verrottete vielleicht wieder hier
rein jetzt mal ganz kurz hier item
sortieren idiot ich wollte ich jetzt
gerade eine timeline blenden aber macht
ja keinen sinn
ich packe mal vorne das glas wein das
passt nicht so ganz das fordert das
fleisch kommt vornherein die erde haben
wir hier vorne drin mit dem sand und so
hier kommen die rail sachen rein da muss
ich demnächst wirklich das ganze
projekt unterwasser tunnel ein bisschen
kritischer angehen
allerdings wird das auf jeden fall
kommen die lore die loren platziere ich
gleich allerdings würde ich jetzt
eigentlich wochen cup setzen weil ich
jetzt mal ganz kurz mich auf meine
notizen die rechts konzentrieren muss
denn da habe ich auch direkt was
vergessen weil das könnte ich direkt
jetzt noch beim nachmachen
ich könnte nämlich mir mal ganz kurz
meine diamant spitzhacke mitnehmen die
habe ich hier seit fast kaputt da muss
ich ja die glück eins nehmen oder wir
schauen ob wir noch eine verzaubern
können ich lasse es jetzt erstmal oder
wir können es ja mal probieren
theoretisch einfach mitnahm
mit der reise spitzhacke die ich mir mal
ganz kurz berlin 23 so sagt die beiden
untereinander so ich habe auch nur 17
level also ich glaube wir könnten es
auch gar nicht hinkriegen der eisen
spitzhacke auf glück level 3 zu
verzaubern
allerdings probierte einfach mal ganz
kurz bevor ich jetzt die diamanten da
hinten mit der spitzhacke ab bauer also
einmal hier vorne noch kurz den
lapislazuli rausnehmen das rein das rein
und wir haben nur effizienz 1 wir hatten
glück zwei brauchen dafür war elf level
mehr als das kriege ich definitiv nicht
mehr hin von einem pack ich gehe jetzt
erstmal hier hinter und werde nun ganz
kurz die loren dort hinten wieder hin
platzieren weil ja letztes mal von mir
abgebaut wurden als ich einmal den
endermann getötet hatte und als jetzt
gerade auch weil geholt habe also die
loren einmal ganz potsdam und bahnen
hier in unseren bahnhof rein jetzt mal
ganz kurzen brötchen ich werde jetzt ich
kann ihr nichts einblenden
ich vergesse dass die ganze zeit die
sache seit die schneidet diese videos
selber und weiß wie man sprechen ganz
genau wann ich was irgendwie einfüge und
ich finde und das ist auch der grund
warum ich in den ersten 64 folgen nicht
gemacht habe mit dem
dass ich mal ein bisschen weniger
geschnitten habe weil das die magie
finde ich wegnimmt von dem ganzen
projekt das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen arrogant dann wenn ich sage
dass hier eine gewisse magie besteht
aber ich finde dass auf jeden fall so
und ich empfinde das so dass wenn
deshalb war es überhaupt
[Musik]
doch das war hier vorne dann musste man
hier irgendwie rein glaube ich hier
unten gehen mit links unter genau hier
gings montag dann sind wir hier in der
höhle angekommen ab ich sehe überhaupt
nichts also zumindest jetzt muss ich so
ein bisschen mit mit kritischer musik
hier arbeiten weil sonst wäre das hier
überhaupt
ich sehe gar nichts daten sind die
jammern aber ich sehe einfach nichts
die könnten ganz recht in welcher kommt
und mich davor verschließen sich selber
ab so selbst die kann ich relativ wie
sie töten zeigt diesen tod noch mal
schnell fakten hinter vorne sind
diamanten
wirklich immer ganz kurz den zombies
kann noch soviel abreise an
normalerweise würde ich jetzt auch die
ganze zeit diesen mit ihren lieben und
bibi hier anfing habe ich auch gar keine
blöcke jetzt muss man ganz klar erstmal
ein bisschen stein nehmen damit ich die
diamanten japan kann und eigentlich kann
ich dir auch ohne ab und ich höre hier
schon wieder irgendwelchen zombies weiß
allerdings nicht wo ich hätte einfach
hier vorne und hatten diesmal ganz kurz
weg zu jetzt nehme ich mag eben fix
meine spitzhacke und wir schauen mal
eben wie viele die aber nicht
herausbekommen wir haben auf jeden fall
ein paar mehr 34 56 77 nicht abgegangen
acht diamanten haben wir und es sind nur
zehn geworden leider also mit der gf3
spitzhacke hätten wir wahrscheinlich
safe g20 diamanten gehabt oder so ich
gehe allerdings bald ganz kurz wieder
hoch denn wir haben extrem viel heute
mal wieder auf unsere trikots
defizitziele das so dass hier vorne weil
der wasserfall
wir haben extrem viel wieder auf unser
to do liste heute ich habe mir ein paar
sachen aufgeschrieben die alle ein
bisschen weniger zeit brauchen sagen ich
mal sonst hatte für die ich jetzt nicht
groß irgendwie datei platz gebraucht
hätte die beispielsweise strandvilla im
netter habe ich ja teilweise wirklich 30
minuten am stück irgendwie fad
zusammengesucht deswegen hab ich mir
heute eher ein paar aufgaben rausgesucht
die wir mal erledigen müssen ein
bisschen einfacher zu erledigen sind
also die diamanten haben wir aus der
unterwasser höhle geholt jetzt möchte
ich noch bei der kloster bei der villa
möchte ich da hinten denen sind jetzt
gerade gar nicht allerdings möchte ich
den großteil durch see laternen ersetzen
das finde ich ein bisschen schön das
habe ich ja schon in der vorletzten
folge gesagt wo wir in dem ozean
monument waren und deswegen habe ich da
auch die prisma in scherben und chris
martin kristalle großzügig abgebaut
allerdings merkt ja auch schon ich kann
mich überhaupt nicht so wie sie
konzentrieren auf das thema was ich
eigentlich wurde anfangen wollte
zwar war das ja das thema energie in
diesem projekt und ich hab den kommentar
immer so ein bisschen ignoriert von
wegen macht mal uncut weil die folgen
dann einerseits extrem lang geworden
wären da habe ich die sachen gepackt
hier
okay ich habe auch perfekt viele teile
dafür ich habe extra vorher mal das
dings ausgeguckt ausgesucht nicht raus
geguckt weil das rezeptpflichtige
hinkriege nicht braucht halt genau 24
stück und genau diese habe ich und der
rest kommt hier in die mitte dann
kriegen wir nämlich see laternen davon
brauchen wir genau sechs stück den rest
packen wir dann wieder hier vorne rein
und ihr seht dann auch schon direkt das
wird nicht deutlich besser aussieht ich
brauch ein paar blöcke kurzem ich hoch
zu bauen
nehme ich mir einfach kurz die erde das
sollte glaube ich reichen die elf stück
das sie deutlich besser aus als das mit
dem glos doch man sieht ist zwar gar
nicht so richtig
also wartet sich eigentlich nie meinen
weg ich war hier immer wieder auf's maul
geht doch schon die sonne unter dass wir
vorne müssen wir auch noch weiter bauen
ich habe auch schon überlegt ob ich das
tier dann generell alles auch unserem
glastunnel baue das hier einfach unsere
ruhe haben wir nicht auf den gleisen
proben hampel den welche zombies oder
weiß nicht was ich möchte das hier auf
jeden fall aus dem senat einen machen
und jetzt wird der ein oder andere
wahrscheinlich sagen und lukas rupp doch
mal
man sieht er jedoch nicht so richtig ja
aber ich finde oder zeige ich euch da
ich das mal als beispiel mit denen
daneben
ich finde dass man das schon krassen
unterschied also wir gehen jetzt mal
einfach ihr sohin zack zack bauen doch
jetzt mal ganz kurz wieder ab
dann zeige ich euch das mal eben also
hier sieht so aus und hier vorne sieht
so aus vom licht wenn nur das hier vier
anschaust sieht es genau gleich aus
allerdings passt dass hier einfach
deutlich besser zu dem ganzen strandhaus
finde ich deswegen werde ich genau das
gleiche jetzt auch noch hier auf den
anderen beiden seiten machen also hier
einmal die beiden eisen fall schon ab
und zeigt dir das floß den weg die
laterne laterne eisen falsche reisen
falsche und hier vorne auch du weg
den habe ich schon glücklich fangen
können kann ich den ja von anfang an
perfekt becker mich zurücknehmen so
nämlich was das heißt wir müssen leider
demnächst nochmal darunter allerdings
weshalb ich auch noch das ist ganz
wichtig ausdenken das kannst du dir doch
nicht ausdenken wieder wie wir sollen
das aber es ist auf jeden fall schon mal
deutlich besser aus mit enthalt wenn ich
jetzt das licht die deutlich kleiner aus
und gar nicht mehr so gelblich also das
licht hat sich beim scheint noch ein
bisschen verändert wie hinten da wird
mir auch und in die kommentare
geschrieben was ich euch jetzt auch
nicht einbetten kann aber an die
personen das waren habe ich zwei und am
letzten video dies geschrieben haben
welche preciado eure kommentare sehr und
das werde ich denke ich auch noch machen
ich hab das nämlich zugebaut diesem ofen
oder diesen mist hier informieren
beck ist aber nicht der von unten oder
ist der eigentlich noch da
ich höre hier unten auf jeden fall
irgendwann die sache ist dass dort unten
ja immer noch der willicher zombie ist
und da ist halt das ding dass mir da
auch keine kommentare geschrieben wurde
das muss sich aber auch mit michael j
hey ich habs geschossen
ich gehe es war eben kurz erstmal
pendler mit die zombies und monster weg
gehen das weiß ich gar nicht mehr wohl
stehen geblieben war
allerdings wurden auf jeden fall auch
die kommentare geschrieben wie ich den
zombie wieder zurückverwandelt das
müssen wir auf jeden fall auch noch
machen ich streiche auch mal ganz kurz
diamanten weg und glos dabei wieder
durch sedat herren ersetzen
da müssen wir allerdings die nächste auf
jeden fall nochmal unser ozean moment
nach vorne einen besuch abstatten um
halt die restlichen partien kristalle
oder scherben keine ahnung was jetzt
genau braucht und warum ist ja eine
schildkröte weg mit dir weg mit euch was
ist denn hier los
ich könnte so viel arbeiten jetzt gerade
mit dem text das funktioniert einfach
nicht in sonderfolge und darauf wollte
ich ja gerade auch noch mal kurz
eingehen die eisen fall warte ich wollte
erst mal ganz kurz mit gras holen so
jetzt mal ganz groß wie beim thema
bleiben so ein gras sollte denn die
reichen zacken das verrottete fleisch
sportliche reise eins kann ich hier
reinpacken andere kann ich kein pardon
geben
in kloster und staub dem pack ich hier
rein und die teile packt auch mal nach
vorne rein so dass hier für dich zack da
freut er sich und jetzt ganz kurz mal
eben mit im gras zurück nach dahinten
das glas wenn ich allerdings auch schon
mitnehmen haben wir eigentlich hin in
den höfen auch noch glas das gar nicht
ich glaube wir haben das rausgenommen
weil sonst hätte ich ja auch nicht so
viele ihrem start von den ganzen sachen
ein halbes deck lasse ich allerdings mal
hier falls wir hier nochmal was brauchen
wir uns nicht alle sind bei der
strandvilla aber der großteil auf jeden
fall so dass wir halt wissen dass das
ich jetzt hier vorne mal lang so dass
wir halt wissen dass das ist ja da
spiele ich keine ausrasten also dass wir
auf jeden fall wissen dass der großteil
auch für den tunnel hier vorne ist ich
bin in der aufnahme bei ich brauche gar
nicht sagen ist ja dann schlussendlich
auch die richtige aufnahme bei 13
minuten jetzt mittlerweile werde jetzt
allerdings auch nur ganz kurz vorne bei
der strandvilla eben kurz das gras
hinsetzen einmal war und hier vorne die
alten falltür einpacken und auch das
ganze glas so den rest den ich hier habe
den benötige ich auch die pfeile
passiert auch was man hier rein ist bei
64 stück ja schade da müssen wir uns auf
jeden fall die nächste mal im moment
bewegen allerdings und jetzt gerade
nochmal auf das maggi thema einzugehen
das problem ist halt dass das projekt
oder was heißt das problem ich finde
auch irgendwie das coole ist dass das
projekt halt durch meine schnitt art so
ein bisschen lebt grothum arroganter
sich jetzt vielleicht habe ich darüber
dass das projekt nicht so cool wäre wenn
ich jetzt nicht diese ganzen jahr soll
man sagen diese ganzen effekte
reinpacken würde sind jetzt zwar keine
kranken special effect in die richtung
bordeaux plane explosionen und hier
kommt die einblendung und blabla ich
arbeite ja gar nicht so viel mit
einblendungen allerdings sehr viel halt
mit tönen mit sounds mit einer
verschiedenen musik die ich heute auch
so ein bisschen drin habe aber ich habe
jetzt heute halt keine krassen irgendwie
pokerstars wenn einmal der hund was sagt
und dann mache ich den text darüber dass
manche leute nicht weil ja wie gesagt
einige halt sehen wollten wie die folgen
wären wenn sie umgeschnitten werden
und ich finde da wäre es halt ein ganz
normales langweiliges singleplayer
microsoft project und das feierlich hat
eigentlich nicht so deswegen wollte ich
halt damit so ein bisschen aber ich
versuche zumindest das projekt dadurch
so ein bisschen und in normalen
minecraft irgendwie anzuheben
also das ist mir halt gefällt und viele
sagen mir auch immer herr luca wenn der
schnitt zu lange dauert teilweise drei
stunden aufnahme wissen warum holst du
dir nicht im praktikanten er das für die
schneidet hat noch fast jeder youtuber
ja ich finde allerdings und das habe ich
geklaut von casey leistet meinem
lieblings youtuber sei keine ahnung wie
langer zeit
ich finde dass der schnitt der
unterschied ist zwischen dem bild was du
dir einfach kauft was ihnen eine kopie
ist und keine ahnung so dass braune
plätze und nehme ich sogar direkt bei
ein paar mehr mit ihr werde gleich
erfahren warum ich hier alle mitnehmen
aber ich finde dass der schnitt halt
gerade der unterschied des zwischen dem
leeren blatt papier was man sich
beispielsweise kauft und einem papier
wo ein bild drauf gezeichnet wurde die
aufnahme hier ist das blatt papier und
der schnitt ist der zettel das was
normalerweise wird das thema in
vancouver der das was ich hier gerade
aufnehme ist das blatt papier quasi und
der schnitt ist so der pinsel mit dem da
drauf gemalt wurde und das fertige
gemälde und ich finde wenn du mir ein
leeres blatt papier gibt es und du mir
sagst zeichne mal selbst das einfach ist
eine kartoffel und dann gibst du meinen
kollegen das gleiche blatt papier und
gleichen stelle sagt auch zeichen der
kartoffel derzeit eine ganz andere art
hoffe und ich möchte selber mit meinen
videos so zufrieden sein dass sie mir
gefallen und das kriege ich nur wenn ich
selber schneide heißt das denn er gibt
dass ich voll und ganz verstehen dass
viele youtuber da ja als sich irgendwie
katar holen und wenn ihr natürlich viel
mehr hochladen und zwei transporter
macht das natürlich auch sind zum
beispiel schaut euch ein paar luton an
ich habe geisteskranken respekt vor
piloten erlebten die zwei videos am tag
hoch und noch auf den zweit kanal und so
dagegen mache ich ja nur alle zwei tage
aktuellen video und so was willst du da
nicht hinkriegen wenn du es alleine
machen würdest was ist das da hin
es ist einfach er das schaut mal wie
sich da vorne die strandvilla aufbaut
und von herrn schneider insel auch
selten gesehen also habe ich schon oft
gesehen aber mit dem leuchtturm auf
dahinten der so im horizont steht das
ganz geil ich fan sage ich als gelber
wie so ein paar hochhäuser bauen
überhaupt nicht passen zu dem ganzen
projekt weil das ja alles sehr ja doch
so ein bisschen mittelalterlich ist hat
man das überhaupt so nennen kann ganze
richtung hier allerdings wenn dahinter
jetzt ein hochhaus einfach wäre oder so
bin ich auch irgendwie falsch
werde aber ein bisschen langweilig zu
bauen 15 nicht dass jetzt in seiner
angst hat folge machen würde aber das
will ich immer noch impuls wenn man hier
hochladen dann siehst du da oben so den
dings ihr fragt euch jetzt gerade
wahrscheinlich also das erst mal ganz
gut zum thema magie und so also gar
keinen spaß so richtig auf zudem ist es
was cool das ist es was neues das ganze
hier nicht zu schneiden allerdings ist
es auch irgendwie komisch wenn mich und
ich glaube auch das ist niemand so
richtig groß feiern wird allerdings
wollte ich einfach mal machen und dann
habt ihr das gesehen dann könnte er
sagen ob es euch gefällt er könne alle
und zumal jede zehnte folge ist dann
vielleicht auch ungeschnitten oder so
dann kann ich dir vielleicht ein
bisschen länger machen aber heute habe
ich mir wie gesagt nicht so große sachen
vorgenommen denn eine der hauptsache die
leute vorgenommen haben also ich habe
fünf bis heute aufgeschrieben einmal
balu von der bahnstrecke holen die
diamanten aus der unterwasser wieder mit
der glück spitzhacke abbauen den
clustern bei der villa durch sedat
ersetzen die drei haben wir bereits
fertig jetzt kommen nur noch zwei sachen
die wir heute zu tun haben uns war
einmal brauchen wir dieses feminine
spinnen auge das mal haben wir uns
gemacht aus so braun pilz und dem
spinnen auge und da bei uns das jetzt
gemacht haben kommen wir damit jetzt
auch zu fünften und letzten sache die
ich von heute vorbereitet habe denn wir
bemüht dass die perfekte situation
gewesen um das richtig geil zu
bearbeiten das ist alles halt nicht
gestellt dass es nicht geklappt hat so
das sind einfach irgendwelche mops so
ich kann ihn schlagen oder selbst keine
gute idee jetzt ist er weg 14 vorne lag
er war jetzt steht ihr so und ich gucke
eigentlich guckst du ihnen heimlich koks
ihn an und er geht so es denn daraus
dass wir sogar gewesen als auch egal ich
brauche auf jeden fall ein paar
wasserflaschen davon habe ich auf jeden
fall noch ziemlich viele und extras und
was ich auch noch brauche ist spart wo
habe ich dann hier haben schwarz
brauchen noch einen schwarzen was ich
dann auch noch brauchen ist ein goldener
apfel und das war es dann auch denn wir
müssen wir ganz kurz braunen die
richtigen profis kuppe
ich habe gerade kurz überlegte
draufzulegen immer noch witze erzählen
lassen aber es würde auch nicht
funktionieren
genau durch das sind alles so kleine
insider hh kann ich von euch schon
wieder was streichen stand will er die
höhle bei der kirche die höhle bei der
kirche soll das kann ich auf jeden fall
was hatten wir nicht in zombie will der
kann nicht auch gleich streichen denn
das ist das was jetzt machen eine
liebevolle und da muss ich euch jetzt
auch einfach mal den kommentaren werden
weil sie hat sich so viel mühe gegeben
bei dem kommentar
deswegen ja danke dir auf jeden fall für
die tipps jetzt schaue ich aber mal ganz
kurz ob wir hier noch glas und aha wir
haben unseren spaß hier vorne am start
der woche hier immer noch ein bisschen
glas und hier und hier das pack ich denk
doch mal zurück allerdings hat sie mir
da bin ich wirklich sehr sehr dankbar
ganz ganz ganz ganz lang erklärt wie ich
das denn hinkriege diesen zombie wille
job zurück zu einem normalen villiger
werden zu lassen und dann kann ich
vielleicht vor diesem sinne ja auch mein
lesepult stellen so dass er dann der
vernünftige bibliothekar wird und dass
ich bei ihnen dann schlussendlich
irgendwann in ein paar folgen bücher
eintauschen kann
deswegen danke dir auf jeden fall für
den kommentar ihr seht ihr schon denkt
sie mir eingeblendet aber dass du dein
herz denn ihr seht schon ich habe hier
ein trank der schwäche jetzt fragt ihr
euch wahrscheinlich was bringt denn
trank der schwäche so damit schwächster
julia nourney umgekehrte psychologie ich
stärke den quasi dadurch man fügt
doch man fügt untoten lebewesen in
minecraft also beispiel schon mal ganz
kurz das schwarzpulver rein das besagt
einfach nur dass das hier dann kein
trank der schwäche wird so dass ich ihn
trinken sondern dass man ihn werfen kann
ob jemand anderen
und wenn ich denen zum beispiel sind
dank der schwäche auf balou schmeißen
würde oder auf dem schwein oder
irgendwie sodann wird deshalb würden die
tiere halten schaden nehmen wenn ich das
allerdings auf den zombie werfe dann
heilt man ihnen bedeutet durch deswegen
werfen zum beispiel die wie heißen die
hexen bei überfällen oder so werfen die
tränke der schwäche auf ihre leute weil
sie die dadurch stärken und mich
gleichzeitig auch schwächen das macht
zeit bei überfällen doch gerade dann in
der dritten vierten fünften war ziemlich
schwierig allerdings kann ich hier mit
inhalt stärken und dementsprechend
wieder zurück zum leben wohl die frage
ist wo er sich befindet hier vorne ok
perfekt ist auf jeden fall noch da muss
er nur hier hochkommen lässt sich warum
diese ganze blöcke hier sind auch die
habe ich dann nie hingesetzt das war
wahrscheinlich gesagt geändert werden
bei uns nicht in so hier irgendwie an
die hier sorgte so kann auf jeden fall
ankommt und jetzt muss ich ihnen wohl
hier mit abwerfen perfekt den hessen
schon mal nicht getroffenen den zweiten
habe ich getroffen und den dritten habe
ich jetzt im trend ich habe jetzt auch
schwäche perfekt und jetzt muss ich ihn
mit dem goldenen apfel twittern
es hat sich an der greif ich einmal noch
an
ich dachte gleich wenig mehr an jetzt
beobachte das ganze mal von hier der
ganze prozess und das ist derzeit der
sache da würde ich jetzt auch gerne
teilnetz einblenden
der ganze prozess soll laut ihrer sorge
laut ihrem kommentar
bis zu fünf minuten gehen und das könnte
jetzt ein bisschen dauern
also ich muss jetzt hier tatsächlich
warten ich will das jetzt auch nicht auf
die nächste folge verschieben weil ich
halt wissen will ob das ganze klappt
oder nicht
allerdings kann ich in der zeit die auch
mal ganz kurz alles so ein bisschen
ausbessern bzw mir auch gleich mal ein
bisschen mehr erholen und das hier vorne
ich weiß noch gar nicht wie ich das
mache dann kann ich endlich meine tür
hin bauen also ich gehe mal ganz kurz
einmal schnell hoch hier fordert soll
ich mal ein bisschen zeit lassen kann
auch gern herr die sonne geht allerdings
auch schon wieder unter von der man ganz
schnell das noch mal eben kurz mit der
tür gemacht da nehme ich mal die aktien
für die brauchen wir nicht weil ich die
mal ganz kurz dahinter platzieren einmal
schnell an ihm vorbei gesamtjahr
das klappt bauen ihnen hier abbauen und
jetzt können wir hier nicht nur
hinsetzen so dass wir hier quasi mal
durchgehen können weil zombies et cetera
könnt ihr nicht wie eine tür durchgehen
ich setze den hier glaube ich auch hier
oben drauf dann sieht es da ein bisschen
schöner aus erbes wieder angegriffen wie
lange dauert das denn als wenn das jetzt
wirklich so lange dauert ich dachte es
ist jetzt nur soja als könnte so lange
dauern wird aber nicht mehr gut die
sonne geht auf jeden fall schon darunter
von daher geehrt ich mich direkt
schlafen legen wir haben in der heutigen
folge noch keinen spieler gesehen
allerdings sollte man den tag nicht vor
dem abend loben meine lieben freunde
sehen wir ganz schnell hier neben rhein
gesprungen und dann mal gucken ob es
dann mit dem zombie eventuell schon was
geworden ist bz wenn ich mir da noch mal
ganz kurz ein bisschen
bruchsteinen holen und den dann glaube
ich da unten rum setzen das ist ja auch
noch ein projekt was wir haben das habe
ich ja damals mal gesagt dass ich das
auf jeden fall auch noch angehen möchte
er ist leider immer noch einen zombie
villiger ich möchte mich unten einen
bunker bauen und das will ich wirklich
demnächst mal machen denn dann können
wir hier unten so ein klarer man sich
befindet ihren goldenen apfel und jetzt
attackiert mich immer noch die ganze
zeit da können wir ziemlich hier unten
sondern kleine schutzbunker einbauen und
so ein bisschen verschanzen wenn
irgendwie leute kommen die uns irgendwie
töten wollen irgendwelche zombies etc
und da habe ich mir auch schon vorlage
rausgesucht kann ich euch jetzt nicht
einblenden
da wir heute ohne schnitte arbeiten das
tut mir leid dass ich jetzt nicht
komplett ohne schnitte gearbeitet habe
allerdings bin ich so ein bisschen
hintergrundmusik und so ein bisschen
abwechslung ist auf jeden fall wichtig
wie dann braucht er denn der ist auch
richtig am zittern sich verwandeln ich
bekomme jetzt macht hat anton den ganzen
tag zeit
glaubst du wohl nicht noch mal eben kurz
laser luca toni denkt jeder ziel mehr
als erreicht
ihr geht es gut er privat leider immer
noch ein bisschen das macht jetzt auch
gar keinen sinn ehrlich gesagt dass wir
sie auch mal dazu gebaut habt denn der
musste jetzt die wieder raus also komm
mal bitter aber mit sehr gerne ich weiß
nicht ich bin jetzt hier zurück holt er
ist auch leider fischermeister es ist
noch ein fischer meisterkader die
richter müssen mit handeln krass ich
mich auch schon gefragt ich hatte
irgendwie hatte ich auf jeden fall schon
raus gechartet sage ich meiner sehr
läuft auf jeden fall auch wieder zurück
zu seinem seinem ort wurde er aber wir
haben es aber auf jeden fall geschafft
freunde also er ist er ist zurück der
fischermeister er befindet sich wieder
auf unserer insel gehört wieder zu den
lebenden das haben auf jeden fall nicht
hingekriegt also danke dir auf jeden
fall für den kommentars hat auf jeden
fall geklappt sehr sehr sehr sehr geil
dass die vorne sieht jetzt ein bisschen
besser aus wir haben hier unten das war
ja damals unsere zuckerrohr farben der
in wien nicht ganz so richtig geklappt
beziehen was habe ich mich ja dann doch
dazu entschieden dass ich anders machen
weil ich dann ja eh auf doch keiner
dings mehr braucht es hat das jetzt hier
das ist experte müssen dann der
fischermeister das ist auch ein experte
da oben gegangen
[Musik]
wenn er jetzt oben im baum aus ist wenn
das der idiot war der mich die ganze
zeit im baumhaus belästigt hat ist ja
auch keinen
denn fast mehr aber wo ist er denn dann
hin gelaufen das habe ich dann auch hier
vorne fässer oder aber der kann man
jetzt nicht so schnell rüber gelaufen
sein
hier ist auf jeden fall jetzt ein bauer
[Musik]
hier ist lieber die sind ja auch keine
fest ist ja auch kein fass ist ja denn
jetzt nämlich komplett dumm oder ist
jetzt schon wieder gestorben oder bot
schon wieder von einem zombie
angegriffen
die freunde läuft noch irgendwer lang 1
eigentlich müsste es doch ihr sein oder
der fischermeister auf jeden fall statt
wieder antwortete doch viele angebote
gibt denn jeden zweifel kugelfisch ich
will mich für die miss markt geben dann
hätte ich nämlich inzwischen können wir
besser machen
was hat er denn hier von angel
haltbarkeit 2,1 für noch ein smaragd
wenn man nicht mal können wir waren auch
schon ob man kriegt er erfahrung dafür
wenn man trailer doch keiner wusste ich
gar nicht richtig
wir haben uns auch tatsächlich noch gar
nicht so richtig auf unsere fischerinsel
hinten gestellt und mal so richtig
gehandelt denn da kann man ja wirklich
auch keine bücher angeln immer nur was
an gekriegt da braucht man aber glaube
ich ein bisschen mehr als nur köder 1
und irgendwie was vernünftiges zu
fingern wir können mal gucken ich an
geräte einfach mal drei mal und in der
zeit quatsch ich noch ganz kurz ein
bisschen denn ich glaube ich mache das
relativ häufig allerdings find ich kann
man es nicht häufig genug sagen ich habe
mich für ein friseur nicht seiten ganz
auf null gemacht haha drinks richtig mit
köhler in rom kabel ja auch was man als
nächstes tun
zwei hohe kabeljau dir mal besser du was
kommt als nächstes setzen
ballacks wahrscheinlich nächstes auch
ein rohr kabel gibt es oder kommt
da kommt der dritte ruhe kabeljau
naja was ich gerade sagen wollte war
dass ich mich das war etwas krasses das
ging so voll weit runter das war locker
einwahl oder irgendwie so
aber da kam nichts ich zu spät komme
dass er wieder kaviar weil er nur so
leicht runter gehen kann dann macht das
wirkliche unterschied aber dann hab ich
gerade einfach vertagt
ich hoffe das war noch kein richtig
krank das buch ist auch egal was ich
sagen wollte war oder kommt wieder was
da kommen ja besser kommen es geht es
ist ein es ist ein rohr lachs es gibt
tatsächlich ruheplätze dann scheint
macht dass ich mal ganz kurz weg dass
ich direkt sehe was ist damit
was ich sagen wollte war dass ich mich
kurz bedanken ich habe er schüsse
ich wollte mich bedanken für euren
support und ich weiss ich mache das
häufig allerdings finde ich kann mir das
nicht oft genug sagen das ist
geisteskrank was aus diesem projekt
geworden ist allein wenn man sich ich
will mich jetzt gar nicht umknicken um
gucken wir die kommt schon wieder war es
wieder ein lachs gabriel will sich dass
die anguckt so dahinten der leuchtturm
hier vorne mit der strandhaus villa die
mob farben die nutzen wir auch irgendwie
noch gar nicht so richtig da müssen wir
jetzt auch mal wieder hin werden die
trauer in sie mit der kirche finde ich
sehr sehr idyllisch sehr schön hier
generell die fischerinsel bewusst grad
befinden da hinten dass villiger dorf
wir müssen doch immer noch den kopf
hauen das war schon wieder in rohrlack
wir müssen auch über den kopf bauen
dafür benötigen wir allerdings
kakaobohnen kommen wir demnächst aber
wir müssen niemanden dschungel suchen
also demnächst geben auf jeden fall auch
wieder auf reise schreibt mir gerne in
die kommentare
was ich in den nächsten folgen machen
soll weil der liebe freunde wir brauchen
ziele
es muss auch gleich noch mal ganz kurz
hinten zur wand hin laufen und das
schild wegnehmen von wegen ich muss den
kombi wieder zurückholen allerdings wenn
die lieben freunde würde ich an der
stelle
lange da ist wieder so ein bisschen
weiter runter gegangen allerdings war es
nur eine andere
ich finde an der stelle des heutigen wir
jetzt auch beenden die erste fast
komplett ungeschnitten episode minecraft
mit luca männer lieben freunde wenn es
euch gefallen hat weil diesen blick sag
ich mal hinter die kulissen so leicht
weil mitzubekommen mal zu sehen dann
lasst gern einen daumen hoch und ein
video hier da abonniert main kanal und
klickt auf die glocke er jedoch kein
teil der lupo seit ich könnte so ne
sache gerade hinschreiben allerdings
werdet ihr das dann in der nächsten
folge wieder erfahren meine lieben
freunde also wie bereits gesagt aber
liegt der main kanal lasten daumen hoch
da wenn es euch gefallen hat wir sehen
uns in der nächsten episode übermorgen
selbstverständlich um 20 uhr wieder und
dann werden wir dinge tun die man gern
schreiben könnt mich alle so krass an
haut rein habe ich liebte sie
[Musik]